[Música]
que sobra del destino que guillermo
valencia este ángulo
la noche del 8 de mayo un grupo de
pistoleros disparó contra la camioneta
en la que se suponía que viajaba pero él
había cambiado de vehículo
por lo que creemos que eran gatilleros
profesionales que alguien contrató para
venir a hacer ese trabajo y que tenían
tiempo siguiendo mis pasos el caso de
valència es sólo una de las siente una
agresiones que según cifras oficiales se
han dado en el proceso electoral al
corte del 21 de valle
ese día guillermo hizo ajustes en su
campaña me iba a caminar me iba los
tianguis a los mercados ya no pos
mi actividad pública disminuyó
drásticamente
[Música]
y ahora si trae una cometa blindadas no
la traía
un amigo pues es un chaleco antibalas
ante la violencia en el proceso
electoral el gobierno federal puso en
marcha una estrategia de coordinación
integral si se definen acciones para
proteger a los candidatos
visitas domiciliarias oa su lugar de
campaña puede ser también contar con
escolta con un auto
preparado para ello es decir el nivel de
riesgo es directamente proporcional al
nivel de apoyo
si las autoridades reconocen sólo 13
homicidios pero consultoras como
integralia y jet elec señalan varias
decenas más algunos aspirantes se han
retirado otras amenazas pero valencia
sigue en el proceso electoral más grande
y complejo de la historia del país